it's been nearly two months since five
people were shot and killed in this
residential area of plymouth
now the police watchdog says it's
investigating an officer and staff
member at devon and cornwell police over
their handling of jake davison's shotgun
license and previous assaults
in a statement the independent office
for police conduct said after reviewing
information obtained so far we have now
issued a gross misconduct notice to a
member of police staff and a misconduct
notice to a police officer
we are investigating the police staff
members handling of mr davison's
original application for a shotgun
certificate in july 2017
as well as their decision to return mr
davidson's shotgun and shotgun
certificate in july this year
separately a police officer is facing a
misconduct notice over how they handled
assaults on two young people by davidson
last september which led to the 22 year
old's weapon being seized we know that
it wasn't the police that pulled the
trigger and committed those murders but
we also know that if there were failings
then people will need to be held
accountable for that but in my mind we
need to look bigger than just whether
devon and corn will follow the right
procedures
this is a situation that now needs top
to bottom review of gun licensing we
need to have a better understanding of
social media better understanding of
mental health as part of giving out
certificates devon and cornwall police
have acknowledged the watchdogs interim
findings and say the staff member and
officer involved have not been suspended
and that the issuing of such misconduct
notices does not necessarily mean that
disciplinary action will be taken but
the issuing of a shotgun to davidson in
2017 and the weapon's subsequent return
just weeks before the attack are clearly
areas of serious concern
davidson had made online posts
discussing firearms law and this ongoing
report raises the question over whether
checks are strong enough
anything involving an arrest or
an allegation
of a violent or aggressive nature
will normally be a trigger to the police
refusing the person's application or
refusing to renew their certificate
where
an individual has their certificate
seized and their suitability is being
reviewed
the kind of steps the police will take
may well include
looking at the individual social media
output the iopc says its report into
devon and cornwall police will be
completed by the end of this year
dan white said sky news in plymouth